welcome back to New rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what's
waiting for you beyond the inky Veil
that separates the land of the living
from the great Eternal Beyond hint it's
a giant water park could you imagine
could you imagine a a water park where
no one can pee in the water that's right
oh that's good that's my heaven as soon
as you let it go you get zapped out
you're Zapped out so make sure perfect
you die in your swimsuit or not you know
whatever you want this is our Heaven oh
this is like a nude water park before I
die I'm like wait
whatever you're wearing you take it to
the afterlife that's how it works God my
wrist watch
um my name is Jessica Clemens and I'm
here today with off-screen producer
Brandon Barrett hello Jessica I'm so
glad to be back with you on the BQ thank
you what's our big question for today
sorry I don't have well I don't have
freaking Capri Sun today so I'm drinking
Kool-Aid yeah it looks like you're
drinking wine in the morning it isn't as
Kool-Aid it is complete this is not wine
look at it you can see through it could
be a box wine it could be a box wine you
know I love it uh low tannins low
tannins well let's talk about the big
question Jessica we just had the release
of Thor love and thunder and we got yet
another look at what could be
potentially waiting for someone in the
MCU after they Shuffle off their mortar
coil that's right the MCU is chock full
of afterlifes there's so many to choose
from uh and it seems like they're ready
to just keep adding options as we keep
going through all these new films and
this new phase so many after lights uh
so many afterlifes but what do all these
afterlifes really mean it leads us to
this week's big question are all the
different MCU afterlife's connected
connected you tell me I can go I can go
see the hippo
open the door
to like Zeus yeah you could hop around I
think you can hop around there's an
American Chavez I can just jump through
different Heavens yeah yeah there's like
the living America Shabbos and the dead
America oh her dad is just always
going to different afterlife boom that's
a free one Kevin feige take it there you
go there you go there you go but let's
let's break it down and see what we know
because as we begin to comprehend what
all these afterlifes mean for the heroes
and just the regular old civilians in
the MCU it does start to feel a little
chaotic the MCU really does attempt to
Define and connect its story elements as
much as possible sorry possible is what
I know what you got on your mind I see
it hey you're at Olive Garden imagine
the possibilities okay that's a free one
Olive Garden you can have that one oh my
God
Jesus Christ
we'll get to him we'll get to him the
MCU really does attempt to Define and
connect its story elements as much as
possible but all these different
afterlifes appear to have different sets
of rules and implications for their
inhabitants it's a little confusing so
let's see if we can break down what we
know about the post-death existence in
the MCU and see if all these afterlifes
are truly connected because remember it
was Tower at that beautiful hippo lady
who mentioned that there wasn't just the
afterlife but rather many quote
intersectional planes of untethered
Consciousness what a beautiful way to
describe death I think does taurette
herself really know how all these work
she is a God after all right she should
know or she's just guessing as well like
do the gods not even know how the
afterlife's work I think they know
they're kind of on the land of the
living I think they know how their yeah
their own works so she's like yeah we're
all tethered while Zeus is like you
can't come in here unless you're special
and she did say she did say the
ancestral plane was beautiful so I she's
seen it for sure but was that like on
accident did she like step through like
a portal or something I was like whoops
wrong
uh also there since there's like a lot
of gods that represent different P
different situations and hers is like
birth right it's like birth and babies
yeah yeah yeah especially in like
Egyptian mythology like as you go on
like different areas ascribe different
things to their gods so why wouldn't why
wouldn't Greek mythology why wouldn't
you cross paths with the other person
that's like yeah totally so it's like it
makes sense that you're probably like we
go to a meeting at the Hilton every year
it's a convention meeting and we talk
about this city the city of uh
omnipotence
omnipotent City they meet up there post
orgy uh they talk about how things work
out a little bit I mean side BQ real
quick side BQ okay when when she's when
Tara is talking to Mark and Steve even
she's like oh we haven't had someone
pass through here for a while which I
thought was like really bizarre right
because like isn't she dealing with like
the Dead all the time but she has to
like dust off the scroll and she's like
she didn't remember what to say I think
that a lot of people
I think it's hard I think it's so hard I
don't think do you the the idea of
literally you have to have enough
balance in your heart I know I'm gonna
die with vengeance I'm gonna die
some sort of hatred with vengeance even
if I get hit by a car would be like that
so it's like I will not die with him I
will kill everyone
okay she did say that she helped uh uh
what's her name what was the woman's
name
it's uh not Maya uh uh don't put this in
oh God oh God I'm like in uh Layla
Layla's father
says she helped Layla's father get into
the field of reads so was he like the
last guy to come through in a while I
don't know I also don't know how he had
a balanced heart he died in front of his
daughter that's it that shouldn't
unbalance your heart it's not his fault
yeah I would be so mad I'd be like oh my
daughter saw me bleed out yeah but maybe
he did a lot of good and it balanced out
that that last minute of of bad I'm sure
he's stole it from someone okay keep
going sorry I'm sure he stole from
someone okay so let's start off with the
most recent entry into the mcu's
Afterlife catalog Valhalla baby this is
the afterlife realm saved for Asgardian
Warriors who die in battle perhaps
horrifically uh if you believe Thor's
side of it uh but we've heard we've
heard third mention of Valhalla before
in the Thor movies but it's usually as
an adjective to describe a delicious
feast or like a brave and heroic feat
however Thor 11 Thunder confirmed it to
be an actual afterlife option Valhalla
is real you can go to Valhalla uh
Valhalla is of course mentioned in real
Norse mythology in that mythology
Valhalla is an actual big hall within
Asgard itself that is overseen by Odin
and when you die in combat in Norse
mythology half of the souls go to
Valhalla while the other half go to
folkvanger folk vonger folkfunker which
is like a giant Meadow where they hang
out with the goddess freyja and it's
just kind of random like half of you get
to go to Valhalla uh where where you'll
you're gonna you're gonna play a role in
Ragnarok uh because like Odin's gonna
need you when the whole Ragnarok thing
goes down because like even when you're
dead in Norse mythology you still have
to keep fighting like it never [ __ ]
ends but the other half the other half
just randomly go to this field which is
just like you're this is the afterlife
here you go you made it to the field
you're done uh that's all you got to do
well fighting's like an honor so that
makes complete sense that they're like
I can't wait to fight unlike unlike me
who is like a gatherer I'd be like I
don't know I just want to pick Bears
I'll help cook food at the at Valhalla I
don't need to be doing the fighting
that's okay now within the MCU we have
seen Valhalla and both Jane Foster and
Heimdall are there Thor and the others
like laid out the rules for entering
Valhalla good to be as guardian and die
in battle but Jane is obviously not as
guardian and she was able to get in and
when Odin died he didn't die in battle
but he still did like the gold Stardust
thing indicating that he went to
Valhalla as well so I think these like
rules they're kind of like loose rules
right I think it's like they tell like
little Asgardian kids like oh you gotta
die in battle mainly because they want
them to fight all the time and that's
how you get into Valhalla but really if
you're just like good and you're as
guardian or like you follow the
Asgardian ways you're gonna get into
Valhalla like that's that's an option
100 I feel like a lot of people are
talking about like Loki right the Loki
who died at Thanos his hands and had
like made good he probably got into
Valhalla don't you think yeah absolutely
he is absolutely there we just had too
many characters in Valhalla to like and
also I'm sure Taiko was like yeah they
don't want to show their behind all and
um Jane Foster than Jane Foster and Loki
she'd be like what that would be a
sentimentary yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
sweet but in theory like Odin's hanging
out in there Frey is there everyone's
just like chilling or freaking living
everyone but Thor
he does at some point but yeah so like
that's Valhalla it seems pretty nice do
you think like the average as guardian
citizen gets in if even if they don't
die in battle if you've been a good ass
Guardian Citizen and you've followed all
the rules he said you have to get to go
to Valhalla he said Thor said himself
you have to die in battle to go to that
at the end I have not rewatched in the
last five weeks but like I thought he
mentioned something at the end that was
like as Guardians can go to Valhalla I
don't think it's as Guardians have to
fight in the war or maybe it was someone
else said I think they just I tell I
think they tell him that battle thing
when they're younger so they're like
you'll just always be fighting and you
you won't like turn away from a fight
because like well I need to go to this
fight so I can get into Valhalla but
really as long as you were good you you
protected Asgard at some point you I
think you'll get it you'll get in parent
Square real talk you would have to share
Valhalla with the guys from Mad Max Fury
Road and I would never want to be there
with them
yeah that's a different one I'd be like
what is that witness means
I was like okay you settle I'm a God
you're a maniac you're a crazy person
okay so that's Valhalla but now let's
talk about the classic MCU afterlife
realm the good old ancestral plane the
afterlife that is part of the wakandan
mythology we of course saw in Black
Panther as a place where t'challa could
commune with his ancestors and other
former black panthers but presumably any
wakandan would have access to the
ancestral plane yeah I think anyone that
ate that herb can see the ancestral
plane but I think I think it's anyone in
wakanda I don't even think it's the herb
thing that you have to do well how do
you see it then wow
so like the ancestral plane we saw in
Black Panther does have a lot in common
with Valhalla in that it's a place for
warriors but there is probably a place
where like the regular civilian Souls
can go chill out as well right because
in Civil War after his father is killed
t'challa describes death as quote a
stepping off point you reach out both
hands to Bast and segment they lead you
into the green veld where you can run
for ever I think this sounds really
familiar to like the field of reads
right as part of Egyptian mythology it's
horrible why would I want to run forever
but I also think it's a play because
they all turn into damn Panthers so
Panthers like to run so here's how I
they do like to run here's how I see
Jessica like if you're a black panther
and you eat the herb yes right yes
you're gonna see the ancestral plane you
get to see it early yes you get to see
it before you actually die yes uh but I
think when you die as like a wakandan
citizen and like you're you believe in
like what kind of Mythology you follow
bass and segment and all that you die
you get brought in a very Egyptian style
you get brought to this like field this
beautiful home and like that's where
your family is yes you're not seeing all
the other families like you're hanging
out with like your family uh and
whatever setting that feels most
comfortable to you 100 right it's almost
like it's almost like Mormonism you get
your own Planet baby uh you get your own
little field where you get to hang out
now I think because these Realms right
are kind of like dimensions and we we
know that they intersect each other I
think you could probably visit other
people's like ancestral areas if like
you were friends with them if you were
like oh I'm gonna go check out my buddy
like his his ancestors are over there
let's go I'm gonna go talk with him yeah
don't you think yeah I well I think the
which it might be deeper in the comics I
honestly don't know but I think there is
a really big point to like a family tree
in there so I think you were just with
your face oh okay and that was your tree
of cats uh your tree of cats but I think
I mean that sounds nice but honestly
like I don't want to spend eternity just
oh I wouldn't I need to go I would love
some other people buy mine my mom like
not my mom but like my grandmother would
still comment on my weight like even
dead she'd be like you're a fat cat well
plus you'd be there in like your great
great great great grandfather would be
there and he'd be like I can't believe
they started letting women vote and
you'd be like all right I don't even
talk to you I'd be like all right what
are you doing here like a normal cat go
to the corner by myself and curl up into
a ball but I do think I feel like the
ancestral play yes
I feel like the ancestral plane in um in
Black Panther can be tied to the field
of reads easier because
um yeah right Africa
but I think I I think there's a line way
more especially because you have Bass
who is the Egyptian goddess that is a
part of black panther so I think those
ones will be more like not even a
doorway it'd be like a hallway to each
other versus Valhalla to this if that
makes sense yeah that makes sense I I
like that that they're a lot closer
because yeah like in the MCU Bast is
like part of the any Edge and I wonder
if like raw was like wait did you just
go make your own afterlife like What's
Happening Here we have this whole thing
set up and bass is like it's cool I got
these wakandans and like my people I'm
gonna do my own thing I guess you're
you're a God if you have a follower a
following so I'm sure the other gods
could have that same situation but do
the gods think of it as like a full-time
job of like oh I don't I have to create
an afterlife for these people now that
they follow me I'm sure there's Gods out
there that are like yeah they praise me
but I don't have to create an afterlife
for them this is the religion part that
I have no idea about right right well I
think what we saw at the beginning of
Thor love and Thunder with that Sun God
is like the most accurate where it's
like he has this Oasis and he's doing
his thing and like if you show up it's
like yeah cool whatever just stay in the
corner don't bother me like I think like
these gods they have these afterlifes as
a place for them to hang out yes and
it's like The Souls of their followers
keep showing up and it's like yeah it's
cool 100 because it's like this weird
realm this like astral plane like
there's a theory it's like Infinite
Space just go hang out over there don't
bother me please go be with your family
and the tree in your weird old backwards
thinking relatives and don't bother me
relative I liked it I'm having a feast
here I like the idea of like the gods
are like this was supposed to be my
afterlife and you guys just keep
following me I wish I was never in the
books I wish you would have never shown
right I wish I was never I didn't want
to be I didn't even want to be in the
Box my dad made me I didn't want to I
didn't ask for this God I'm like and
then word choosing based off which ones
we like I'm like I'm coming to the field
of reads and I'm following you when I'm
following you when I'm coming so far I'm
into Valhalla where there's at least a
structure I can hang out I don't want to
be in a field just running around by
myself like bored as hell like when Mark
when Mark got to go into the field of
reeds uh and it was just like him
hanging out I was like this is boring as
hell truly just like the beauty and S
like essence of this like oh this is
gorgeous for the first 10 minutes and
you're like okay are there ticks in This
Tall Grass
where do I use the restroom yeah is
there like a book I can read is there
the internet here like what's happening
so I just sit here and wait till other
people show up and there's maybe only
three of us
well let's let's talk about that field
of reads that boring field of reads
Jessica uh because the afterlife
construct we were introduced to in Moon
Knight took the form of the duat and the
field of reads this was like a
two-parter okay uh Egyptian mythology
does not make entering the afterlife as
easy as just dying okay as you mentioned
earlier your heart has to be weighed
against a feather on these like scales
and if the scale's balance you're
allowed to pass on to the field of reads
uh the version of paradise also known as
aru if not balanced well you go into the
sand into the litter box baby and like
that's where you hang out forever I
guess what a boring boring way to go
could you imagine what I thought most
the Panthers running into the sand and
oh maybe the Panthers use the sand as
the toilet
here's the thing Jessica if I die and go
to heaven and I still have to use the
bathroom I'm gonna be so pissed why like
that I like using the bathroom yeah you
only like it because the your body's
filling up with garbage you gotta get it
out like just make Heaven a place where
I can eat but everything's taken care of
it goes you gotta do the I understand
yeah I don't got to do the after stuff
actually no I want to be in Black
Panther because I want to turn into a
panther that uses a giant litter box
which is something
just pissing on your enemies because you
died full of Vengeance yes my heart
doesn't need to be balanced some of
black panther
well Jessica what I found most
interesting about the Egyptian afterlife
presided over by the iniad is the fact
that it's more of like a two-stage
process right first is the do what and
then the rest is the afterlife this is
kind of like having like Purgatory where
you go to before you after you die and
before it's decided whether you go to
like heaven or hell right you kind of
have this like weird two-stage process
uh when Tau red is talking to Stephen
and Mark she describes that as quote the
realm of the duet so this kind of
supports the idea that these afterlifes
are like other dimensions connected to
the to our universe right they're kind
of little pocket Dimensions that exist
in the weird space in the four
dimensions or whatever and Tara is sort
of confirmed that these Realms are
dimensions uh intersect right if there
are intersections that means that
there's a possibility to cross from one
into the next you know kind of like
we've seen with incursions or the
convergence or what's happening in Miss
Marvel where there's like this kind of
veil between two Realms that are on top
of each other uh so yeah I think it
really I think what Tara had said those
like little couple of phrases she kind
of explained the Afterlife with she
really confirmed this idea that there's
all these Dimensions connecting right
yeah uh and that's kind of like a big
thing in phase four with like Loki with
all the like timelines breaking right
all the multiverses breaking all these
incursions they're really every angle of
this uh kind of phase of the MCU is
about like dimensions and other Realms
that connect with each other which is
why I think you should be able to go to
like different afterlifes like once
you're once you're dead it's like you
get a festival pass you go into your
main tent right whether whether that's
Valhalla whether that's the ancestral
plane but after you hang out for a
little bit you can walk around to check
out the other half to life I think they
should go visit some of your buddies um
they should give me the press pass and I
get to show up and just wander through
and take photos but I also think so I
okay so if we're mirroring what is
happening currently I think that would
make sense that there's different like
like how we have different timelines we
have different dimensions here of
different religions I think that yes
that makes sense there has to be one
person that can go through them all
just like how it was like Wanda could do
it with the help through America Chavez
who can do it all I want there to be
that American Chavez for the afterlife
and I'm sure yeah we could see it
eventually but like there has to be one
there has to be that one person that's
like that would be interesting I'm a
dead person and I go through every
everything
oh my God they're like get out well
Jessica we should also talk about like
the Soul Stone okay because during the
events of infinity war and end game we
gotta look at some form of afterlife
presented by the Soul Stone you know
like after Thanos sacrifices Gamora and
he's in that weird little watery place
and he sees like baby Gamora uh and
there was like a deleted scene when uh
uh Tony does his snap he like saw a
grown-up version of his daughter in that
like watery area or whatever it's kind
of this like sort of endless puddle
where you can interact with the soul of
a lost one or maybe just like your own
mental projection of that person it's
tough to say they don't really Define
what it is but there was like a lot of
similarity between what that Soul Stone
afterlife looked like and what we saw
when Gore Thor and Jane made it to
Eternity in Thor 11 Thunder and
eternities kind of hanging out in that
watery Place do we think that's the same
place or do you think they just liked
the water effect and like I think they
probably uh did the water effect but
doesn't mean that they can't go back to
it it doesn't mean they can't use it
right so I I feel like at the time they
probably did it because of that but now
they can tie into it I don't know if
they're gonna remember that though I
don't know because it's like if if
Infinity right had the ability or I'm
sorry if eternity you had the ability to
kind of like bring love back right like
bring back a life bring back a soul
maybe eternity exists within the soul
stone or that weird Soul Stone place is
controlled by eternity I don't know I
think it's very it's so similar it
didn't have like the oranges glow that
was the only main difference I don't
know too much I like the idea of those
things being connected I don't know much
about eternity is crazy I
eternity is like one of those like Old
School Big G gods that just like shows
up when like the universe is like about
to be collapsed and it's like hey I'm
the universe what are you doing what are
you doing
yeah I don't know if it in the comics
it's not always like this like wish
granting thing uh that I think that was
something they came up with for the
movie and really it was only like I only
Grant one wish to the first person who
gets here I don't know what eternity
does after that just like hangs out I
don't know they're like and 20 minutes
I'll restart and you can get another
wish yeah okay anyone can come by I
don't know why they're waiting so uh
yeah why isn't anybody coming here I
feel like they would have known that
I've been hiding in here this entire
time that's the only thing also for 11
Thunder I was like if eternity's been
here the entire time feels like we
should have jumped to her a long time
ago I call her her because she's a yeah
eternity can just wait forever eternity
doesn't process time again it also
looked very boring in the water
afterlife of the Soul Stone like put
something in here you and the Beautiful
atmosphere you are so you I don't think
you would survive in a room
I need entertainment I need consonants
give me a
PlayStation yeah yeah well let's also
talk about Zhang Chi for a second while
we never saw an afterlife realm in
shangchi we did see the physical
manifestation of souls right those
beautiful little marbles coming out of
people uh as they were devoured by those
tentacle uh having Soul suckers getting
sucked out yeah very disturbing stuff uh
since there are souls you know since
shanxi showed us that our physical souls
and like everyone's got one it would
stand to reason that there's a realm for
them somewhere I don't know what the
people of talo believe I don't know what
the people uh in Shang Chi where like
their souls would go do they get to go
to Valhalla I mean they're fighting
against a big monster I don't know give
me a second but the big question is
Jessica if the all those Souls that got
eaten by the dweller in darkness is his
is his belly like a hell you know what I
mean if you get eaten is your soul like
trapped inside of there and when they
killed the dweller did those Souls get
freed or they do they just get it like
wiped out of existence I think they just
got wiped out of existence like if you
die in heaven or hell it's like you're
gone for eternity I don't know if you
saw the girls gone for good good yeah I
don't know if you saw the greatest movie
of all time Inception but when you got
to the lowest I didn't see the
conception and you die there and you're
just gone that's what I just got I liked
the message and shangshi the
Chao low people where it was like
I just can't remember what they were
like religiously because they were
weren't they living for a very long time
well yeah they were there was magic
there and they were they were keeping
the the seal that kept out the dweller
in darkness they were protecting the
seal and they do live a long time they
have the magic inside of them
inside of them
so maybe they just become Guardians and
then they are Guardians for the the
dragon that helps well I like the idea
that like the dweller in darkness he is
like a hell version of afterlife right
and if he gets your soul you're trapped
there forever and that's why they're
keeping him out of our universe yes to
protect our universe but also to protect
all the souls and to keep everyone from
like getting devoured by the dwellings
yeah that's true letting hell physically
destroy the Earth so you're telling me
right now that he's Gabriel
um I only know religion if I come back
to Christianity
well here's here's a little Christianity
for you Jessica okay if there's all
these afterlifes in the MCU and most of
them are presented as sort of like a
Heavenly Oasis then does that mean that
there's another side of the coin is
there a hell to all these Heavens okay
we did see in uh Doctor Strange of the
Multiverse of Madness when they were
going through all those multiverses
there was that bone one with like fire
and skeletons and everything made out of
bones that kind of looked like a more
traditional version of hell right we do
know there's a Mephisto out there
somewhere he hasn't really been
mentioned yet but in theory he's ruling
over this Hal Dimension that could be
his there's all this dark magic right uh
you know that like Agatha hardness and
Wanda maximos have used that's coming
all that dark magic comes from the dark
dimension but I think the dark dimension
presided over by dormammu is like a
version of hell right if if you worship
him and he takes your soul you're like
stuck on that little you're stuck in his
Dimension right huge Darkness he's all
consuming uh and we also know that there
is a hell h e single L and this is where
Odin banished hella after she tried to
pull a Kendall Roy and take over the
family business okay how is a region
it's a region of niflheim which is one
of the infamous nine Realms and it's
also the home of the Dead uh in the
comics like hella runs hell and it's
actually named after her but in the MCU
hell is where she was like banished to
and it's just kind of like a place for
the Dead who don't get into Valhalla or
the field that makes sense
I don't think there's a hell for
um the uh astral plane in um black
panther because I don't necessarily
think
um uh what's his name the brother
um Sterling K brown or the dad were both
good or bad uh they both like he killed
his brother and he still got to go live
a peaceful Life as a panther in the
perfect purple it's kind of messed up
well that's why I said shallow was like
I reject all this this is BS like you
guys are not good people you did bad
things so you can hear hear it here you
guys you can murder someone and go to
the Black Panther I'm so sorry yeah
it oh my bad but if you are Brandon
you'll probably get so bored and want to
leave yeah
go to hell it's way cooler well you fail
to read you'd be like this is
this is this is my own hanging out with
my family in the field of read so oh my
God that's Florida that's Florida
that's why I left that's why I left
well the hell h-e-l that hella is
trapped in it's not really like a
traditional punishment hell which is
more popular in the Anglo-Saxon
Christian religion right they're the
ones that made hell like this awful
terrible place where you'll you'll
you'll burn for a thousand years like
that's all Dante's Inferno kind of
nonsense uh but yeah the he single L is
more of like a warehouse of the Dead
where neither the honored nor Dishonored
Souls just kind of like wind up as it is
what it is but yeah like I was saying I
think dormammu is like hell I think he's
the the hell to all of these Heavens if
you get consumed by him that's where you
go now my question for you Jessica if
you remember right kaisilius and all of
his followers they were trying to bring
in dormammu and their punishment was
like they get sucked into his like Realm
the ancient one right she's dying she
knows she's gonna die she pops into
Spirit form and she's like look at me
holding on to this moment because I
don't want to die did she wind up with
dormammu did she get sucked in well she
did have a little bit yeah right I think
she got something I assume I think she's
trapped in there you can't um
without going to hell
that's right don't don't play The
Devil's fiddle unless you want to go to
hell
[Music]
that's where I think she wound up and
maybe like Doctor Strange is going to
run into her in the next one when he's
hanging out with Clea having a badass
time going to dark dimensions he's gonna
be like hey weren't you my boss she's
like I'm in hell get me out of here I
made a mistake I shouldn't they use the
power I'm so sorry and then he's gonna
be like you know mordo you're trying to
kill me in another timeline
it's all because of you all because of
you you keep ruining this for me
hey Doctor Strange is the problem I've
said it before and it was proven true in
the movie I think that was the problem I
we've already talked about this brand I
think we're on the same side I think all
the Avengers are the problem
when Tony Stark is was the everything
the route to everything bad at the
beginning
this freaking guy they've got to be
stopped they gotta be stopped this needs
to stop now so Jessica in the end do we
think all of these afterlifes are
connected I think I think they are I
think some are I think some have their
own as most religions do I'm really
attached to the field of reads and like
those Gods just because one of their
main Gods is the god for black panther
so I think when it's stuff like that
those are those ones are yeah 100
connected because I'm sure for Valhalla
all those gods are still attached uh uh
Zeus Greek mythology isn't Valhalla
right that what do you mean you don't go
anywhere the name is Hades Lord of the
Dead how you doing there is an afterlife
there's definitely an afterlife because
oh there's the you can go to hell
eurydice and stuff where yeah yeah there
is like a down and there's an up
it's just kind of like it's just kind of
it's not like punishment down it's just
like boring down you know like you in
this boringness you I clearly have
something dude life is too much I don't
want to spend eternity doing something
else even let me sleep you didn't know
give me the big sleep oh God I did it
enough
I did enough so yeah we think the
afterlifes are connected I think they
are and I think we're gonna learn more I
think you're right Jessica that they're
going to introduce a character who can
jump through afterlife and that's going
to be really cool but hey be sure to
head on over to newrockstarsmerch.com
and check out all of our cool merch
especially our new latest Obsession
shirt inspired by Thor love and thunder
it's an awesome look for the summer and
there's lots of other cool other summer
merch you can find on new
rockstarsmerch.com right now thanks to
our partners at epic hero shop for
putting this awesome merch together uh
it's a great way to support the channel
so be sure to check out all of our cool
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help us bring
big question to you after years of fine
print contracts and getting ripped off
by big Wireless providers if we learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch sort of like the afterlife the
catch is it's boring but thank all the
gods out there that mint mobile is out
there offering premium Wireless starting
at just 15 bucks a month and the best
part there's no catch mint mobile secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only
they cut out the cost of retail stores
and pass those sweet delicious savings
directly to you many folks here at new
rockstars have made the switch to Mint
mobile and they love the quality service
they get as well as the savings they get
compared to their old service providers
plus you get to transfer your contacts
and keep your phone it's super simple
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile offers premium Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month mint mobile gives
you the best rate whether you're buying
for one or for a family and all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any met Mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all of
your existing contacts switch to mate
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month you
can't beat it folks to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to Mint mobile com slash big
Q that's met mobile.com slash big Q cut
your wireless bill to just 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com bigq I love my
computer and all the wonderful things it
can do and that's why I want to keep it
safe safe from all that evil out there
that's why I turn to services like Avast
Avast is a global leader in cyber
protection for more than 30 years and
trusted by over 435 million users and
prevents over 1.5 billion attacks every
month a vast new all-in-one solution a
vast one helps you take control of your
safety and privacy online through a
range of features a vast one is the best
protection yet giving you everything you
need to take control of your safety and
privacy online and accessible through a
single easy to use interface a vast
multitude of features provide you with
privacy and security as you scour the
web and even help with your machine's
performance I like their award-winning
antivirus that stops viruses and malware
from harming my device as well as their
data breach monitoring that will alert
you if your your online account has been
compromised plus I feel confident using
public Wi-Fi with their firewall
protection burning away all the hackers
with their wall of fire I don't know how
a firewall works but a vast does and
that's why I like using it thanks to
Avast for supporting big question
confidently take control of your online
world with a vast one it helps you stay
safe from viruses phishing attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes learn more about avast1 at
avast.com again that's a vast.com from
being shocked at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts damn you inflation that's
why at new rockstars we've started using
upside upside is an incredible app for
anyone who buys gas groceries or dimes
out with every purchase you can earn
cash back thanks to upside use that
cashback to buy the perfect souvenir on
your next road trip or maybe a little
gift for your loved one to get started
all you got to do is download the free
upside app in the app store or Google
Play use promo code big question that's
all one word big question and get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more in
comparison to Credit Card Rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more cash back with upside you can
cash out anytime to your bank account
PayPal or an e-gift card for Amazon and
other brands upside users are earning
more than a million dollars every week
that's probably why they have a 4.8 star
rating on the App Store I've used upside
myself it's great it's a great way to
figure out where you want to eat
sometimes the wife is like hey where
should we eat dinner I don't know I
don't know you go back and forth all the
time I just pull out the upside app I
check out where I can get a reward and I
suggest that restaurant she has no idea
and I look like a genius it's great
check out upside for yourself it's
really easy to use and I really enjoy
using it myself download the free upside
app and use promo code big question
again all one word big question to get
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of 10 or more that's five
dollars or more cashback back on your
first purchase of 10 or more using promo
code big question all one word no spaces
in there big question are you ready for
somebody
[Music]
quick it's gonna go from Miami
girl
side BQ why is it why why is Phoebe
being driven at a funny girl why are we
giving it to Leah Michelle who can't
read okay okay that's a vicious rumor
hey Leah Michelle and I'll say with my
full chest get her out of here that's
the reason just leave me okay no
whatever no whatever our sponsors like
oh Leah Michelle because we shouldn't be
with them if they lovely Michelle
let me ask you a bite size question ask
me a bite-sized question you ready
why is there no sanctum protecting the
Southern Hemisphere or is there one
where is it and why is it not being
acknowledged from hide the worm on
Discord great name yes great name thank
you hi deworm as Wong so eloquently
describes in the first Doctor Strange
film Earth has three sanctums shielding
the planet and they are located in New
York Hong Kong and London as he says
quote agamoto built three sanctums in
places of power where great cities now
stand so either agamoto new great cities
would rise up in these locations or the
sanctums attracted people who built
great cities it's a chicken or the egg
thing I guess I don't know either way
it's clear that agamoto didn't feel like
building sanctums in the southern
hemisphere was he scared of the Equator
uh did he hate having summer in December
I don't know it was very uh European of
him to not go down to the Southern
Hemisphere and build a sanctum I don't
know why he didn't do it but we do know
that Wong also shows that those three
sanctums they build a shield that's big
enough to cover the whole earth so I
guess they didn't feel like they needed
to build another sanctum down south I
don't know but the three sanctum
solution is a product of the MCU because
in the comics Stephen Strange's mansion
in NYC is the sanctum Santorum and
actually technically it's like a room
inside of the mansion that's the sanctum
sanctorum but whatever and the sanctum
in the comics is more of like a weird
House of Magic than a piece of the
master of the Mystic Arts security
system right it has like this really
bizarre history with many weird owners
uh and it has even been burnt down and
magically restored many times over the
years and in the comics nobody even
knows who the original architect of the
sanctum Santorum was uh and Stephen
strain says he just bought it because he
liked the people in the village uh the
Greenwich Village he liked hanging out
with them but like he probably knew that
there was something weird going on with
it so yeah it's just kind of like this
strange sanctum in the comics and
there's not like these three synced up
Santorum things in the comics like they
have commentage but there's not like all
these like saying active things I think
they created them for the MCU kind of to
just tell the story with kaisilius and
have like Stakes where like oh these
other two got destroyed you got to
protect yours I don't know why they made
these like three sanctum things but yeah
there's none in the southern hemisphere
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what to tell you I don't know what
to tell you too hot
um if you could okay too too hot if you
could
Bend any
who would it be and who would you cast
says on Discord yes this is a good
question I love this I've been waiting
for uh Marvel and like Kevin feige to
like throw a big like gender swap at us
like change the gender of like a big
hero I hope they do it and here's how I
think they should do it okay we want Dr
Doom let's make Doctor Doom a woman huh
how about that for a swap and don't stop
there okay I think they should swap Mr
Fantastic and Sue storms make sue storm
the one who's like really stretchy and
super smart Okay and then make Reed
Richards just a dude who turns invisible
and makes like Shields you know what I
mean
the elastic girl we get that with
Elastigirl right right and she honestly
yeah is the best character that's why
the second movie is all about her
um that's right that's right those hips
oh my gosh uh don't get me started
but yeah so let's swap let's swap Mr
Fantastic and and visit uh and Sue storm
okay and we have a female Doctor Doom
come in and that should be played by
Lena Headey I think she would be a great
villain a great female Doctor Doom and
it would be so awesome that's my answer
same casting same casting I want mine to
be Lena headache uh she can do both
oh she's such a good villain uh Cersei
is amazing
um horrible I hate Cersei and that's why
Lena head is such a good actress oh so
good so so good I want uh because I
already love what we got with Agatha and
I like what we got with uh Scarlet Witch
so I also want Mephisto to be a woman uh
we haven't seen it yet but I like I
would because it would I want her to
like have that darkness of Agatha mixed
or Agatha when she's like Peak witch in
one division but also like sexy like
hella uh and so I'm like Lena Heady
could do that I love her sisters are
doing it for themselves baby let's go
let's go oh Elena had to do in both
those roles
oh she could write she write it someone
write it for her
oh we're ready for the box of scraps oh
I'm ready for a box of
scraps
Boston scraps what which
I hate this question what would be your
ideal afterlife scenario because if
there's anything I've learned from you
this episode Brandon I think I know what
it is but I would I would love to hear
entertainment entertainment
entertainment baby you know I just like
uh I think like a national park the the
most beautiful National Park ever uh
where I can walk around I can see
beautiful things but there's also like a
mall and a movie theater and an arcade
attached uh and you know I just there's
the entertainment for me so like
basically a national a beautiful
national park with a Dave and Busters
inside of it that's all I need that's
all I need for my afterlife and I'll be
good to go I'll be good to go hate
California more than anything but
but what I think about this all the time
that my heaven would be driving through
the hills through like
um Laurel Canyon deep Laurel Canyon at
Twilight time hanging out on Saturday
with friends during Twilight time that
is my heaven and also a closet full of
cheeseburgers uh that are always fresh
that are always fresh and every time I
opened it's restocked like a Richie Rich
when he has a McDonald's in his house oh
my God I I don't know why cartoon
Burgers get me but they do who's the uh
looks so good I'll gladly pay you
Tuesday for a hamburger today oh from
Popeye forget his name that's me yeah
I'm truly like cartoon Burgers always
look good cartoon uh chicken legs where
you can just like rip it right off it's
90 Meat the pizza and Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles always look so good pizza
in the Goofy movie dude that was like
five pounds of cheese on one slice
give it to me and then beer beer is good
animated things always look so good so
frothy it looks delicious don't get me
started yeah put me in a cartoon that's
my heaven that's my tune my favorite
baby let's go oh let's go thank you
Brandon for joining me or allowing me to
join you for this episode of Bitcoin to
each other Jessica we joined each other
we and we know we will never wind up in
each other's afterlife
follow my grin and bears follow me at
Lulu underscore Clemons follow new
rockstars here on YouTube and all social
media platforms make sure to hit that
notification Bell and be sure to check
out new Rockstar's Discord server if
you're 18 plus and interested click on
the link of the new rockstars Discord
server in the description below I'm
pointing because I'm sure it's below
this and join the conversation bye let's
guess bye bye see you and have fun
master
[Music]